I started cooking when I was 20, 21 years old
after I started studying
architecture,
but I have a brother who is three
years older than me and he was much better at
architecture than me and when I was
studying architecture I left
everything and started  cooking
you are I was very lucky to get together
with four of the best chefs in
Spain with joan roca jordi cruz now
and little by little because I have been lucky enough
to get to where I am now I have a
restaurant in my city apart from that I am
head chef in  a restaurant with two
michelin stars in barcelona
and apart from that i take part in all the
contests i can and there is nothing difficult
because when you enjoy your
job well there is nothing difficult everyone
everything has its good and bad parts
but everything is beautiful and you enjoy everything